Speaker 1: Former President Barack Obama still
on the campaign trail, still absolutely crushing
a lot of the horrible people that are running this
time around. Most recently, former President Obama
was in the state of Nevada. Nevada is a place that
has a very important race going on. It is a race
that is not necessarily going that well for the
Democrat. The Republican running. Is Adam Laxalt
a horrible, horrible person. This is Nevada Senate
and the Democratic candidate is Catherine Cortez
Masto. Unfortunately, Adam Laxalt has opened up
a roughly two point lead, roughly two point lead,
1.9 percentage points over Masto. And he is an
absolutely horrible, horrible candidate. Former
President Barack Obama.
Speaker 3: Obama now.
Speaker 1: Yeah, right, right,
right. But we know his real name.
He called out the rising anti-Semitism that
we are seeing. He correctly identified that
the rhetoric that led to Paul Pelosi being
attacked is likely to do more damage and to cause
more violence. Let's listen to a few of these
clips speaking very precisely on these issues.
Speaker 2: And and. And it
gets disseminated. Millions of
people log on to that. I want
to give you a tip. Nevada. Yep.
I want to give you a tip. If you see or read
something on the Internet that says some people,
certain kinds of people, whether it's whether
it's white or black or immigrant or gay. Or do.
Or Muslim. When you see something on
the Internet that says those people
are the cause of your problems.
That is that is a dangerous lie.
That that that is a pair
that will tear this country apart.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And it's not just
will tear the country apart, but it's will
also lead to significantly more violence.
And in this next clip, former President
Obama makes that point very clear as well.
Speaker 2: Well, a friend of mine, Mr.
Pelosi, was attacked viciously. Somebody
broke into his home looking for his wife,
Nancy Pelosi, the speaker of the House.
And thankfully, I spoke to Paul a couple of
days ago, and he's going to be okay. But.
But but even as investigators do
their job, find out what exactly
motivated this this person. One thing is clear.
This increasing habit of demonizing political
opponents creates a dangerous climate.
And elected officials who do not explicitly
reject or participate in over-the-top rhetoric,
if that's what they're doing
instead, if it if they just ignore
or make light of that kind of violence, or
if they encourage their supporters to stand
outside voting places armed with guns and dressed
in tactical gear. Yes. If that's the environment
that we create, more people are going to get hurt.
Speaker 1: And remember, generically condemning
violence when there is violence, but then
continuing to do campaign ads where there's
targets on people. Or to say at campaign rallies,
someone should really do something about Nancy
Pelosi. This is a really big difference between
the left and the right in the United States.
The right will say. Black Lives Matter is violent
and they threaten people or Antifa does this,
that or the other thing. When you look at the
top level of the people in positions of power,
you do not see the violent rhetoric from the
left the way that you see from the right.
It's what it is. The left doesn't
talk about knocking them around,
alluding to violence, but playing
coy. The left doesn't regularly use
campaign ads with people holding firearms or
putting targets on the backs of individuals.
I know that we can find in a country of 330
million anecdotes of everything but the right,
specifically the MAGA. Right. Mitt Romney really
doesn't do this that I've ever seen him do.
I've not seen Liz Cheney do it. I've not seen
Adam Kinzinger do it. But the MAGA. Right.
Is doing this deliberately and it's not. It
might lead to violence anymore. It's it has led
to violence. It has led to violence. Barack
Obama also weighing in very clearly on the
stakes here when it comes to policy that affects
people versus cultural issues that are contrived
and used to drive wedges between individuals.
Speaker 2: The question, though, you should
be asking is who's going to actually
try to do something about it, right.
Because if you watch these ads, Republicans,
they talk about it a lot. But what's their
answer exactly? What is their economic policy?
Speaker 1: None. Tax cuts for the rich, I guess.
Speaker 2: Don't know. They they've got
one. They want to get Social Security
and Medicare and then give their wealthy friends
and big corporations more tax cuts. Right.
Big cuts. Big end, because that's
their answer to everything.
That's I'm not joking. Literally,
it doesn't matter what's going on
when inflation is low and unemployment is high.
They want tax cuts when it's the reverse tax cuts.
I was telling some folks in Michigan, if there
was an asteroid headed towards Earth right now,
they'd all get in the room. They
say, you know what you mean,
we got to cut cut taxes for the wealthy.
That's that's going to solve it, really.
I mean, I guess it's simple to just have
one answer to every economic problem.
Speaker 3: Exactly.
Speaker 2: I remember,
you know, when I when I had a test in math
and and sometimes I didn't study hard enough.
I stayed up to late the night before. And it'd
be nice if you could just write down eight
on four every answer.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean,
this is just a version of when all you have
is a hammer, everything looks like a nail,
or you claim it's a nail, even if it's something
completely different. And former President Obama
is completely right in that. And he actually goes
further. And again, this is not about glorifying
Republicans of times past. It's not that Reagan
was great or Bush by dear God, it's not that Bush
was great either. It's that there has been a real
observable, tangible change in the way that this
political party, the Republican Party, operates.
Speaker 2: On the one hand, you've got politicians
who seem like they will do anything and
say anything to get power, and leaders who
share our values, who want to make your lives
better, who want to move the country forward.
And let me say this, Nevada, that, you know,
one of the difficult things about these kinds of
rallies these days is, is sometimes this does seem
so partizan as if it's just a Democrat Republican
thing. But my favorite president is a guy named
Abe Lincoln who helped found the Republican Party.
It used to be that there were GOP members
who championed progress in civil rights.
Speaker 1: That was longer ago
than Bush, to be clear rule of law.
Speaker 2: But these days, just about every
Republican politician seems obsessed with two
things owning the libs and getting
Donald Trump's approval for now.
Speaker 1: For now. And as we spoke
about with Angelo Carusone yesterday,
the desperation for Trump's approval may wane
depending on how next Tuesday goes and depending
on what happens with Trump's 2024 candidacy. If
there is one last clip from Obama, he weighs in
on election fraud. Adam Laxalt, the candidate that
he is campaigning against in Nevada, is a big lie
proponent. And here is what President Obama says.
Speaker 2: He has no actual evidence of election
fraud because there's actually no
widespread election fraud. But he's
not going to let that stop him.
Speaker 1: Absolutely.
Speaker 2: He's going to look under every rock in
the desert to try to find an excuse. Although if
he wins, I'm guessing he'll be less concerned all
those votes will be legit. Funny how that works.
Listen, I lost my first congressional
race by 30 points. I got what?
You know. You know what I did not
do? I didn't say this was rape.
I didn't cry in front. I certainly
didn't instigate a riot on the Capitol.
Instead, I asked myself, how can I be better?
Speaker 1: Yeah. Good luck getting Republicans
to ask themselves that question. And of course,
he's completely and totally correct. If you vote
in Nevada, if you vote in Nevada, we do not want
Senator Adam Laxalt. And we have the potential
to see Senator Adam Laxalt and Senator Herschel
Walker. And Senator Mehmet Oz and Governor Kerry
Lake and a Republican governor in Oregon whose
name I forgot for the first time since 1987.
This could get very dark, very, very
quickly. And so we have to vote. We
have to vote is the message. I know
it's repetitive, but it is a must do